لان الى التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا رئيس بلديه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اعلن مقتل شخص واصابه اربعه
بجروح وذلك جراء قصف روسيا استهدف العاصمه
الليله الماضيه اعلنت القوات اعلنت القوات
الاوكرانيه اسقاط 20 مسيره وصاروخاي كروز
روسيين من طراز كاليبر في ثالث ليله من
الهجمات على العاصمه كييف الاداره
العسكريه قالت من جانبها انه حطاما اهداف
جويه تعاملت معها الدفاعات الجويه سقطت
على عدد من المباني الجانب الروسي اكد
موقع ريبار العسكري الروسيه ان القوات
الروسيه سيطرت على مرتفعات مطله على مدينه
باخموت بعد هجوم مضاد وصفه بالناجح وقال
الموقع كذلك ان القوات الروسيه اقتحمت
بلده
شرقيه مدينه ليمان في محور كريميانا بين
مقاطعتي
اشار موقع ريبار الى تمكن الق وات الروسيه
من صد هجمات اوكرانيه في بلدتي
الرابوتيكنو
وباتخاذك في محوري
الجويه الروسيه انها نفذت ثمانيه ضربات
جويه على قوات اوكرانيه على محور كوبيان
قواتها صدت محاولات محاولات لوائين
اوكرانيين مهاجمه مواقع روسيه في محور
كرازني
واضافت الوزاره ان قوتها استخدمت قاذفات
سميتش ودمرت مراكز لتجمع القوات
الاوكرانيه في المنطقه فضلا عن اسقاط
مسيره اوكرانيه بواسطه نظام الصواريخ
واحد المضاد للطائرات
لنتابعه اخر التطورات الميدانيه وبشكل خاص
على الجبهتين الجنوبيه والشرقيه
نعم عثمان وليلى قبل قليل كان هناك تصريح
لافت للمتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه
الذي قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت
فندقا في مدينه برديانسك الواقعه في
مقاطعه
والتي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه قالت
انها استهدفت هذا الفندق الذي تتخذه
القوات الروسيه مقرا
لافرادها وانها قتلت عددا كبيرا من هؤلاء
واستشهدت بمعلومات استخباريه استخبارات
استخباراتيه تشير الى نقل القوات الروسيه
لجثث القتلى في هذا الفندق الذي تم
استهدافه يوم امس هذا اللافت في هذا
مدينه تبعد اكثر من 100 كم عن تواجد
القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
وبالتالي فان القوات الروسيه استخدمت
القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت صواريخ ربما
عاليه الدقه وان كانت لم تفصح عن طبيعه
هذه الاسلحه ايضا قبل قليل كان هناك
حديثي المتحدث باسم عمليات المنطقه
الشرقيه الذي قال ان هناك هجمات وصفها
بالعنيفه على المحاور الشماليه في مقاطعه
دونيس وتحديدا في محوري لمن وهذا ربما
مصداق لتصريحات الروسيه نتحدث عن هجمات في
تلك المنطقه ولكن وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه
فان هذه الهجمات احبطت وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من ايقاع خسائر في صفوف
القوات المهاجمه ايضا يبدو ان هذه الليله
كانت عصيبه على القوات الاوكرانيه هذا
وفقا لتصريح للمتحدثه باسم القوات
الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني نتاليا التي
قالت مره اخرى ان هذه كانت ليله عصيبه وان
القوات الروسيه نفذت هجمات معقده وفقا
لقولها خاصه على
المحاور الجنوبيه واستخدم الطائرات شاهد
اضافه الى صواريخ كاليبر من
سفن وغواصات متمركزه في البحر الاسود كما
تعلم عثمان صباحا كان هناك هجوم عنيف على
هناك احاديث عن اكثر من 20 مسيره من طراز
الشاهد اضافه الى ثلاث صواريخ من طراز
كليبر عدا عن ذلك من جانب المبادره
الاوكرانيه على الاقل فان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول ايضا في بيانها انها
تمكنت من تحقيق تقدم ملحوظ في الجبهه
الجنوبيه من مدينه تسيطر على كل المواقع
وانها ثبتت اقدامها في كل المواقع التي
حازتها خلال الايام الماضيه هذا اذا
استذكرنا ايضا تصريحا سابقا للجيش
الاوكراني لقاده الجيش الاوكراني تحدثوا
عنه احرازهم تقدما في المناطق المرتفعه في
مدينه
وانهم تمكنوا من السيطره عليها وان القوات
الروسيه منذ الان فصاعدا سوف تعاني من
ضربات المدفعيه الاوكرانيه التي ستثبت في
تلك المناطق اخيرا كان هناك حديث ايضا
للجيش الاوكراني قال ان الجيش الروسي زجه
بما يعرف بقوات احمد او القوات الشيشانيه
بالفعل في مدينه باقمت على الجبهات
الاماميه وان القوات الاوكرانيه تتعامل مع
هذه القوات منذ عده ايام